hey how long did it take after you
started to pop off before you hung out
with Iman Shumpert so we didn't so we
didn't realize y'all were the same yeah
it was ASAP it was quick right because
it was like was he on the Knicks at the
time or was he on the Cavs okay okay and
it was also yo bro it was it was I go
live bro it was ASAP man it was ASAP man
it was just like yo the internet picked
up on it I'm like yo damn I do like this
dude
nobody said
you got to take a picture together
I wonder because when you first came out
your the future comparisons were crazy
right did you and future ever have any
interactions or any did you ever meet
him or because obviously he's tied with
with yay and you know but was it was
that ever like did you guys have a
conversation or have any interaction nah
man
and it's crazy because when you talk you
just sound like you so it's kind of was
that ever frustrating here in those
comparisons because you're like I'm just
I'm just me like like the way you talk
is how you sound when you rap so it's
not like you're trying to sound like
nobody yeah bro I don't know bro yeah I
was just telling bro like oh here's the
dude named do you remember gorilla black
from Compton gorilla back Compton so
there's a guy named gorilla black from
Compton okay and he sounds just like
biggie also shine remember you remember
shine first came out people saying but
then when you would hear shine talking
interviews yeah I remember like that's
just his voice
too my brother-in-law was telling me
about him when I was younger too he was
like yo get some kid in gorilla black
bird but that's crazy it's kind of
similar to like yo this is just your
voice like what do you want me to do you
want me to like we have a similarity in
voice what the [ __ ] you want from me you
can't win you feel me I don't know I
don't know man I don't know bro